[Music]
all right joining me now someone would
he just mentioned former secretary of
state mike pompeo distinguished fellow
at the hudson institute also a fox news
contributor
mr secretary um
we're obviously seeing a shift in
governance in the uk
with the new prime minister liz trusts
only two days into the office now with
king charles um
how monumental a week is this not just
for the uk
but for the
entire you know western order given the
passing of the queen
although i had a chance to get to know
the queen just a little bit i just had
that chance to meet her one time she was
a remarkable woman who had given so much
of her life to true service lawyer a
great commitment to others commitment to
country before self she sacrificed so
much in her own personal life
i pray that the united kingdom will have
in king charles the same thing
and that
new prime minister trust will have the
opportunity
she won't have the benefit of 70 years
of experience through thick and thin
good times and bad prime ministers from
the left and the right
but this will change uh leaders all
around the world it was just not inside
the united kingdom that the queen was
important she was important to lots of
different people lots of countries
around the world
she understood dedication and service in
a way that i think and i pray our nation
will get back people who care deeply
about our country and are willing to
fight for it the same way that the queen
fought for her country and for her
leaders
she will be missed
and i was just uh
speaking uh earlier about this idea of
the changing definitions of courage and
bravery valor gutsiness um and she
really embodies the true definition
embody the true definition of those
things where today you know you're gutsy
for just you know saying you want more
me time or saying you want to have more
self-care like that's a gutsy thing to
say in the workplace um but i to me
there there's a nostalgia here but it's
more than that i you talked to a lot of
young people today
they they have affection for her so
there's something about beyond just the
pomp and circumstance
but about her and what she represented
that i think there's an enormous amount
of affection for
you know laura i think you're right i
think all generations could see how
steady she was i think we are looking
for serious leaders who are steady and
who are prepared to stand for the
values and the institutions and to
defend them vigorously not just not just
with a tweet or a snide remark someplace
on social media
but by real service real work real
dedication real wisdom real experience
real knowledge things that this queen
certainly had and that we see lacking
too often around the world both on the
world stage and here at home
can you imagine the queen ever
disparaging her own country the hit
whether it's the history of the country
or former leaders of the country
publicly the way
it's done so glibly and casually
uh today in the united states by so many
people in inf of influence
it's unimaginable and seven decades on
it never happened she not only was
unapologetic about her role in her place
and her country's place in the world but
remember we're now just a couple days
out from 9 11. i remember the queen at 9
11 as well she understood what had been
put upon the world she understood the
united kingdom's responsibility to help
america respond to what happened
to our citizens that day
she was steadfast in protecting freedom
around the world wherever it was
threatened
oh she loved reagan she had a great
relationship with president reagan john
paul the second
obviously
she and trump got along really well
woody and i were just talking about that
um i want to play some other some other
reaction though to her death from some
corners was a bit odd mr secretary
here's former obama official and
journalist rick stengel
british colonialism which she presided
over for all these years was had a
terrible effect on on much of the world
there's a weakness in the american
character that still yearns for
that era of hereditary privilege which
is the very thing that
that we escaped from
what on earth is he talking about i mean
they have contempt for anything attached
to tradition period end of story
unbelievable you gotta ex you got it
exactly right this is an attack on the
foundational ideas of our country we
have a very different system we have no
monarchy here we split away from that a
couple hundred plus years ago
but those histories those foundational
ideas in our country it's our
constitution and our founding that's
that those attacks would be exactly the
same on our institutions the thing that
we hold dear it was kind of a marxist
attack on that it's a that's a bizarre
statement uh from the left who just
literally rejects history and tradition
and values and virtues in the way we all
know have delivered not only for our
country but the united kingdom and the
relationship between our two countries
as well yeah mr secretary they're going
to be really miserable over the next few
weeks of all the ceremonies and so forth
because it's gonna be absolutely
miserable because anytime people are
patriotic they're really unhappy so just
great to see you tonight thank you so
much for joining us